this graduate school was inspired by
George Washington to teach these things
the large things that a statesman would
need to know to govern this country well
what's missing in a lot of politics
today is we have a lot of people that
want to talk about first principles and
of course we have a lot of people that
want to focus just on action it's
connecting the two it's the virtue of
states which do education is about more
than just turning out good workers it
should be about turning out good
citizens as well the next generation of
Americans who understand the timeless
principles of our government and
unfortunately too many schools and
special universities not only fail in
that mission but they actively repudiate
that mission young people who come to
this town don't have that founding
understanding of how government should
be and how it will best operate so I'm
excited about learning the larger story
and how to incorporate the wisdom of
people who came before us into a very
frot culture right now
we relook at core documents original
documents we're gonna study the writings
and thoughts of great statesmen and
great books and it will mostly be taken
by people who work in the government and
they will read old books they'll start
with Plato and Aristotle in Herodotus
and Thucydides and they'll learn what
politics is and then they'll learn what
America is
[Music]
understand how the Constitution works
and then it'll teach the alternatives to
the Constitution that have grown up in
understanding and in institutions in
America that are the abnegation of the
Constitution and then you'll be equipped
to go on in the world and make some
decisions
[Music]
to be fine human being you need to have
a good character to be fine human being
and find its kind of human being you
need to understand the ultimate purposes
of life and everything else and finally
to be a fine human being you need to be
free
we're a college aiming for all those
four things and so the way we're serious
about that is to teach in ways that are
helpful to being better in governing a
free country the United States of
America
we can help ambitious people to
understand what that is so they can
cultivate it there themselves and learn
from it and that is a huge value
[Music]
you
[Music]